imagina que estamos viviendo en tiempos
prehistóricos ahora considera lo
siguiente como hicimos para darle
seguimiento al tiempo sin reloj todos
los relojes están basados en un patrón
repetitivo que divide el truco del
tiempo en segmentos iguales para
encontrar estos patrones repetitivos
miramos hacia los cielos lo más obvio es
que el sol sale y se mete cada día sin
embargo para darle seguimiento a
periodos de tiempo más largos miramos
ciclos más largos para esto observamos
la luna que parece crecer y encogerse
gradualmente durante muchos días cuando
contamos el número de días entre lunas
llenas llegamos al número 29 este es el
origen de un mes sin embargo si
intentamos dividir 29 en partes iguales
nos encontramos con un problema
es imposible la única forma de dividir
29 en partes iguales es descomponerlo en
unidades 29 es un número primo puedes
pensarlo como irrompible si un número
puede descomponerse en partes iguales
mayores que 1 lo llamamos entonces
número compuesto ahora si somos curiosos
podemos preguntarnos cuántos números
primos hay y qué tan grandes se vuelven
empecemos dividiendo todos los números
en dos categorías en list hemos los
números primos a la izquierda y los
números compuestos a la derecha al
principio parece que bailan hacia
adelante y hacia atrás no hay un patrón
obvio por aquí así que veamos una
técnica más sofisticada para ver el
panorama general el truco es usar la
espiral de un lado primero enlistamos
todos los números posibles en orden en
una espiral creciente después coloreados
todos los números primos en azul
finalmente alejamos la imagen para ver
millones de números
este es el patrón de números que sigue y
sigue por siempre increíblemente la
estructura completa de este patrón
todavía está sin resolverse así que
vayamos rápido alrededor del año 300
antes de cristo a la antigua grecia un
filósofo conocido como euclides de
alejandría entendió que todos los
números pueden separarse en estas dos
categorías distintas comenzó a darse
cuenta de que cualquier número puede
dividirse una y otra vez hasta llegar a
un grupo de números iguales pero más
pequeños por definición
estos números más pequeños son siempre
números primos es decir él sabía que de
alguna forma todos los números se
construyen con números primos más
pequeños para ser claros imagina el
universo de todos los números e ignora
los números primos ahora toma cualquier
número compuesto descompongo y siempre
terminarás con números primos
euclides sabía que todo número se puede
expresar usando un grupo de números
primos más pequeños piensa en estos como
bloques de construcción no importa qué
número elijas siempre puedes construirlo
como una suma de números primos más
pequeños esta es la raíz de su
descubrimiento conocido como el teorema
fundamental de la aritmética toma
cualquier número supongamos 30 y
encuentra todos los números primos que
lo dividen en partes iguales a esto se
le conoce como factorización esto nos
dará a los factores primos en este caso
2 3 y 5 son los factores primos de 30
euclides se dio cuenta de que entonces
podría multiplicar estos factores primos
una cantidad específica de veces para
construir el número original en este
caso puedes multiplicar cada factor una
sola vez para construir al 32 por 3 por
5 es la factorización en números primos
de 30 puedes pensarlo como una llave
especial no existe otra forma de
construir 30 multiplicando entre sí
otros grupos de números primos así que
cada número tiene una y sólo una
factorización en números primos una
buena analogía es pensar que cada número
tiene un candado distinto y la llave
única para cada candado es su
factorización en números primos no hay
dos llaves para un candado y no hay dos
números que compartan la misma
factorización en números primos